Let's go back to.
Oh, here.
I think this is a call from.
I think this is a call from Israel.
Let's go to Peleg from Ashkelon.
Peleg.
What's going on?
And remember, you have to UNMIL yourself.
I've brought you in, but you get there you
are.
Hey, David.
How's it going?
Good.
How are you?
Great to talk to you.
What's your lecture yesterday?
It was awesome.
Thank you.
So basically, my question is, if I live in
Israel and I've been here a lot of talk about
Biden and his policy towards Israel.
So from one end, I can I can hear this stuff
like, oh, is yes is a radical and a from another
side I can hear like, oh, is that good for
us?
His friends who are lobbyists and stuff like
that.
So I guess the question is, what's your opinion
about Biden's policy towards Israel and yet
your general opinion on it?
Well, it's not about my opinion.
It's what is Biden said.
So first you said you heard that, but some
people said Biden's for BDA says Biden never
said he's for medius.
I cannot find that.
Yeah, he hasn't said it.
So Biden's not for meetings with with regard
to the relationship.
Biden would be completely unremarkable in
his relationship to Israel.
It would be very similar to Barack Obama.
I mean, certainly if Benjamin Netanyahu is
not a factor, the relationship will be improved
and you might get a credible opportunity for
four serious peace discussions.
But there is going to be nothing remarkable
at all about it.
Sort of like Trump says, Biden will end the
Second Amendment.
No, Biden will try to get some sensible reforms,
pass maybe universal background checks and
a few other things.
It will be very similar to what Barack Obama
tried to do.
Trump says Biden is going to end the suburbs
and, you know, kind of this racial dog whistling.
No, he's not.
And there are some on the right saying Biden
will be terrible for Israel or for American
Jews or whatever.
No, he won't.
He will be completely unremarkable in every
way with his with regard to Israel.
Israeli policy.
Great.
That's exactly what I think.
So I tried to explain that to people.
Great.
Peleg, what's going on now in Israel in terms
of masks?
A lot of people I fall.
I live in Israel.
They're outwell phase.
They're at gyms, not wearing masks.
What's the deal?
Yes, that is a problem.
And we've had, like, a lot of talk about it
and also, like, go now.
Right now, there are a lot of protests against
Benjamin Netanyahu.
Yeah, every like I think Saturday I might
be wrong about it.
So a lot of people don't wear m..
And a lot of criticism about that.
From what I know right now, we are on the
shut down.
It's gonna end like in about five days.
So right now, it's seems to be a steady end
in terms of masks, people generally respected
and.
Yeah.
OK.
Because I don't see anybody wearing masks,
but they respect when it when you're supposed
to.
You're saying people are wearing a mask.
When I usually go out, I see about 70 percent
of people wear masks.
But be be.
That's not bad.
OK.
All right.
Peleg, I'm.
I'll let you go.
Sounds like you're juggling a lot over there,
but I appreciate hearing from you.
Let's go.
We really are taking a tour of the world today.
I want to go next to Eric from Toronto, our
friendly neighbors to the north.
Eric, you can go ahead and unmuted.
And I would love to hear what's on your mind.
Holy crap.
Well, first, I wasn't expecting to talk to
you, but hopefully you're doing well.
I enjoy your content.
But listen, Eric, when I woke up this morning,
I didn't expect to be talking to you either.
So we're both in the same situation.
Well, after watching the debate last night,
I was watching your livestream.
Oh, my God.
Just horrified.
Yeah, I.
I don't know if there's a winner to this debate,
to be honest, and it didn't sway anyone either
way.
It's just it's just unfortunate.
Like people are brainwashed into believing
Trump is just crazy.
And I can't imagine, like, thinking that he
is the choice to pick for this election is
just.
Oh, my God.
I tend to agree with you that the debate.
So if you if you follow somebody who predicts
Hilik elections with a qualitative rubric
like Allan Lichtman, he doesn't think debates
make any difference at all.
And I tend to agree in terms of the math of
it.
The only thing is.
A very small margin in a few states could
flip the election.
So while I don't think the debates will move
the polling significantly, I do recognize
that, you know, if just one percent of the
population in Wisconsin found Trump to be
a petulant child and Biden to seem like an
adult.
Well, that one percent could actually swing
Wisconsin.
You know, you understand what I'm saying?
Yeah, I am.
And another thing I want to bring up while
I'm here is I really do hope the moderating
gets better.
Like, I remember what you're saying.
Like, why aren't they cutting the mikes?
Well, they don't have the mechanism of the
parties.
The parties would have to agree to that to
to give the moderator that power.
And of course, Trump in particular, never
would.
Yeah, and it's upsetting, though.
I mean, you can just see how broken it all
is.
I'm talking with my coworker here and working
at the same time.
It's just like we're both just talking about
how can they not meet the mikes?
Like, what kind of process is this if the
Trump disputes?
Garble over.
Yeah.
I'm like, not that Biden was like anything
to write home about either, like you said.
But no, like I said yesterday, Biden had four
to five strong answers, in particular his
last answer, he had about three zingers and
he had a five or six week moments where he
seemed unable to kind of sequentially lay
out a vision.
And I think that those are the moments that
Trump is going to fixate on.
Yeah.
Every time Biden stuttered, I my heart sank
a little bit.
You know what?
I think he had least in face plant.
Right.
That's the important thing.
And yeah.
You know, I'm just happy to check in with
you.
That's all I really had to say.
Also, hello, Pat.
And, you know, thanks for taking my call.
All right.
Thank you very much.
We're going to say goodbye to Eric from Toronto.
And Pat, you can make a note that people have
said hello, and that's a beautiful thing.
We're going to go to a very brief break.
If you're holding on, don't go anywhere, because
we're going right back to the calls momentarily.